entier cristers tout est fait remarquer
par un bouquin qui s'appelait la vie
quotidienne à matignon durant l'union de
la gauche et tu travaillais avec pierre
mauroy tu écrivais ses discours mans
entre autres est ce que c'est pour ça
qu'il est épargné dans le bouquin que tu
publies chez albin michel il s'appelle
lettre ouverte à la génération
mitterrand qui marche à côté de ses
pompes 8 épargnés parce que c'est un ami
de vingt ans et que respecte toujours
mes amis ce qui veut dire que tous les
autres sont à tmi alors ceux qui sont
cités mais comme il y en a plein qui
sont pas cités on peut penser que
j'avais d'autres amis alors y en a plein
qui sont cités ça va te falloir une
interview vous où ça c'est sûr
[Musique]
on va commencer avec mitterrand parce
que tu y va pas de main morte un tu t'en
prends carrément à dieu ce cas le dira
qu'il est nommé dieu convoi s'amuse
quand même j tout je suis déicide pas
pour toi les mitterrandolâtre la
tontonmania c'est la céleste une
régression intellectuelle terrible 7
degré zéro de la pensée politique du
canton magna oui c'est vraiment le culte
de la personnalité mois quand renault
fait des grandes pages de publicité sur
le thème tonton je t'aime ou qu'englobe
plaidé que ses couvertures sur surtout
ne nous quitte pas et ne voient pas la
différence de nature avec yves montand
célébrer le 70e anniversaire de staline
du même niveau il ya plus grave quand
même c'est quand tu dis que finalement
mitterrand aujourd'hui c'est un peu
franco sur la fin là une technocratie
qui dirige les affaires lui qui est
vieillissant le mythe de l'opus est
grave et bien un truc comme ça mais je
pense que le phénomène de la
technocratie qu'est ce que c'est ça veut
dire que des hauts fonctionnaires ont
pris le pouvoir à la place des
politiques et suffit de regarder qui
sont les chefs de tous les partis ayant
vocation à gouverner juppé tout bon les
hôtes à pabu jospin rocard chevènement
c'est tous des hauts fonctionnaires tu
évoques l'observatoire un moment dans
ton bouquin oui parce que je fais le
rapprochement enfin c'est pas moi qu'ils
les fesses et séguéla avec la génération
morale et la génération mitterrand
regard sur nous raconte a essayé aussi
baptisé génération désirs et ses rebonds
l'a fait passer de morale à mitterrand
c'est quand même sauter par dessus les
grilles du jardin l'observatoire s'il va
pas de main morte alors passons
continuons loulou jack lang jacques
langlois le grand mamamouchi de course
et celui qui traduit dans le monde des
cultures euh ouais les désirs de marquer
une oreille du président donc en fait il
est l'ordonnateur des des foucades
présidentielle et en plus maintenant ce
qui n'était pas tout à fait vrai dans le
premier septennat il est devenu le
meilleur représentant des tropismes du
monde des cultures autres et donc en ce
sens est devenu un homme d'ordre dans ce
milieu là puisqu'il est long
représentant deux l'emportera tisme de
leurs travers kouchner l'aura du bon
docteur qui va sauver les boat people
quand même limité parce que quand
kouchner s'est lancé en politique ça a
été en 80 à droite d'ailleurs puisqu'il
faisait la campagne de marie france
garaud l'ancienne conseillère de jacques
chirac et grâce à kouchner et à
glucksmann aussi d'ailleurs qui elle a
obtenu 1,33 pour cent des voix là il a
essayé de ramener au ps une
circonscription communiste dans le
valenciennois il a ramassé au aussi un
bide assez sévère donc j'en conclus que
quand même son audience médiatique n'est
pas exactement de même nature que son
audience auprès du français moyen en
tous les cas de l'électeur chevènement
de la manière dont il met en scène
l'armée
ou plus exactement dont il permet à
l'armée de mettre en scène certaines
chaînes privées de télévision à thurso
est une avancée qui ont ouvert leur
porte avions parce qu'avant mourousi
ouais quand même très spécialisés de ces
grands shows militaire il utilisait la
télé pour présenter l'armée tandis que
matt avec chevènement c'est mieux on
utilise l'armée pour présenter les
avancées conceptuelles intéressante
attali en ce sens la propriété al talhi
à mon sens la propriété et reste
toujours fidèle à sa niche doré à la
droite de son maître voilà alors séguéla
tu as une phrase formidable tu dis que
c'est le publicitaire que mitterrand à
la france tous les sept ans oui je crois
que vraiment sûr je crois que vraiment
personne n'a fait autant pour séguéla
que françois mitterrand je suis pas sûr
que la mère soit vrai je te fera un
petit reproche parce que tu dis que le
bambin de la génération mitterrand
s'il ya quelque chose il a un petit rôle
en pétainiste mais le clocher en 80 ne
crois pas que il avait un petit relents
pétainistes aussi oui non peut on peut
le dire - jeu comme je m'intéressais aux
couches-culottes cette fois ci je
m'étais blessé pas au clocher s'était
deux futurs bon alors marek halter
baraka le vrai pour l'iss mais aussi
vous explique tout ça donc voila et
marek halter a beaucoup oeuvré pour luce
perrot et puis marc halter qui quand
même et comme chacun sait est un
champion la démocratie a quand même des
procédés oh mon dieu procès barbie qui
me sont restées en travers de la gorge
c'est à dire que m construire un
mémorial devant le palais de justice de
lyon pour plaider l'acte thèse de
l'accusation imaginons qu'on fasse ça
hein moscou à l'occasion d'un procès
tout le monde dirait voyez bien ce
régime soviétique qui bande de pourris
déni de justice et ses abords cela dit
on fait exactement avec marek halter la
même chose en france devant le palais de
justice de lyon alors isabelle thomas tu
dis que c'est une une fleurs carnivores
perdu dans les plans de parade chez les
plantes parasites c'est très bonne
formule quel est mon pire ise par le
phare le vieux monarque à l'isel c est
ce qu on m sont sans frais moi je le
connais pas mais vu à la télé c'est tout
donc je la trouvais plutôt sympa trouve
plutôt sa part plat trouver pourra dire
parce que depuis calme à traiter de
grossier déboutant je la trouve moins
c'est un temps arrêté que de ça c'est
pas grave sandrine aubert donc je la
trouvais sympa et puis je trouvais que
la manière dont cette espèce de crypto
front national qu'elle avait enfin del
re election l'agresser à la voilà la
rendait encore plus sympathique et ça me
trouverais dommage qu'elle se transforme
en une politicienne comme comme les
autres c'est mériterait mieux si l'on se
sent qu'ils ont bien que je les mises en
garde d'accord yann 1,8 à traiter car et
monde compte sur canal oui mais là je
reconnais la finesse de l'analyse du
beauf officiel
est ce que tu crois pas finalement le
désir de monarchie des dans la tête des
sujets le désir de monarchie est
sûrement dans la tête des sujets et
sûrement aussi dans les institutions de
la république cela dit quand le monarque
a mené toute sa carrière ou pour les
trente dernières années sur le thème
qu'il fallait libérer les sujets de
cette monarchie qu'ils ont dans la tête
il n'a pas le droit de la réinstaller
ensuite
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars
10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais un peu
ce bleu